なんか途中でやめてしまったような感じがしますけどね
この前の話は で まあこの前の話をまとめて言うと
全てのものには何も実体がないっていうことをね
しっかりと経験した人で
全てのものと言えば 結局この自分の体のことです
体っていうのはね 色受想行識というルーパーダナーサンニャーサンカーヴィンニャーナという五つに分けてあって
明確にその五つあるということをはっきりわかると
その一つ一つループであろうがウェーダナーであろうが
サンニャーサンカールヴィンニャーナであろうか
ずいぶん勢いでものすごく早く変化して変化して新しいものになっていくんだっていうことがわかってくるんですね
そこでサンニャーというものがありまして
それが自分だ自分だという誤解をする
サンニャーの場合 サンニャーヴィカルラと言うんですね
それで自分がそうやっているんだという誤解がサッカヤディッタが生まれて
その上に他もいるんだというサッカゴダイが生まれてきて
そこで煩悩やら執着やら生まれてくるんだということ
それでその五蘊というものが
この何も実体のない ただの蜃気楼のように
瞬間瞬間因縁によって変わっているものであるんだよとわかったら
一切の色 自分であろうが
自分の色自体がループ自体が無常で蜃気楼で幻覚であるならば
他の色自体も同じことではないかということがわかるし
自分の感覚が瞬間瞬間変わっていく変わっているもので
当てにならないものであるならば
他の人々の感覚でも同じことではないかというふうに理解していくんですね
それで何ものにもとらわれなくなっちゃって
もう何もなくなって消えちゃうというかね
今までのものはって現象であるということがわかって
それで心は煩悩から離れて悟りということになるんですね
そこまで話を続けてきまして
それから悟った人は大変褒めているんですね
いろんないろんな言葉で
槍を抜けた人やとかね
アブドゥル エイシコとかね
パンナダジョー パンナバール
旗を下ろした人 荷物を下ろした人とか
いわゆるもう一切のことは終了した人
もう頑張らなくても踏ん張らなくてもいいんです
用が済みましたということで
もう徹底した心の安定っていうものを生まれてくるんですね
で そこからの話ですね
今日は エヴァンビムッタチッタンコービッカウェビックーサインダデーヴァサブラフマーサパジャパティカーナヴァセサンナアビガッチャンティ
イダンニッシタンタターガタッサヴィンニャーナンティサンキッシャエトゥビックーエワーハンビックーウェダンメータターガタンアナヌウェッジョーティヴァダーミーっていう
ところまで
エヴァンビムッタチッタン
このように心が解脱したならば
ビムッタチッタ 解脱した心ですね
その比丘に対して サ・インダ・デーヴァ
インダさん 主にする神々
インダっていうのはインドの文化的に神々の王様なんですね
インダっていうのは 仏教では一般的に軽々しく使ってあって
インド文化宗教思想ではかなりいろいろ複雑な概念ですけど
インド人がアーリア人がインドを侵略する以前もインドラという神の信仰があったみたいし
それでインドラという神が純粋なアーリア人が信仰していた神なんですね
名前は それでインドにもともとあった信仰していた神様にインドラという名前それだけもダブってしまっちゃったんですね
長い間 年々単位で百年単位で時代変わると
もうかなりこの文化の概念のシンクロナイゼーション
シンセシス シンクレティズムというね
出来事が起きちゃうんですね
一緒になっちゃって新しい概念になるんですね
そんな話はいいと思いますけど
お釈迦様の時代になるとあの時代を生きていたんだから
神々の王様はインドラというふうに思っていたんですね
それからセ・ブラフマカーセ・パジャーパティカー
ブラフマカーっていうのは梵天の神々
パジャーパティカー パジャーパティっていうのは
この梵天の中でもまたかなりの格の高い神一人なんですね
梵天の一人なんですね
一応パジャーパティという名前をなぜ使っているかというと
絶対神ですか 創造神というのは梵天であって
神とはその言葉を使わないんですね
神々よりかなり上の方で考えていたんですね
だからパジャーパティっていうのは人間が作った神ということになっちゃうんですね
お釈迦様はある神の名前としてしか見てないんですけどね
とにかく人々が考えている概念は全部使っちゃうんです
だからパジャーパティ神様を信仰している人々もいるし
一般的に梵天の神々を信仰している人もいるし
インドラ神を信仰している人々もいるし
どうでもいいんです お釈迦様にとっては何信仰したっていうのは
とにかく全部まとめちゃうんですね
アナワセーサンナアビガッチャンティ
そういう人々はアナワセーサン
残りなく どんな神であろうか
誰にでも理解できませんというその一言葉で
その後はもうお釈迦様は結局は否定しちゃうんですね
ある人々にとってはインドラさんが絶対的な神であって
一生懸命信仰している
シヴァという言葉は同時期で使ってないんですよ
ですから こっちは出てこないんで
これは後でシヴァがまた生き返ってきたんですね
シヴァ信仰もやっぱり元々からあったもので
それでインドラ信仰にダブっていたんです
そこでこのシャイシュタっていうのは
ものすごい小さな もうほとんどいないぐらいの小さな信仰宗派でしたからね
それでものすごい後の時代になってから
おそらく紀元一世紀ぐらいだと思います
そこら辺でシヴァ信仰もまた表れになってきたんですね
ですから 現代はシヴァシヴァと偉そうに盛りよく言ってますけどね
昔は別にそんなにシヴァ信仰の宗派っていうのはなかったんですけどね
言葉はあったんだけど
一般人の間ではあんまり知られていない
あんまり多数派ではなかったりですから
経典なんかはね 出てこない
シヴァという言葉だけは出てくる
その場合はこの平安という言葉で使っているんですね
なぜかとシヴァといえば
本当は平安 心の安らぎということがあって
その安らぎ 究極的な境地を得た神という風に定義はあるんですけど
やっぱり後でシヴァっていうのは破壊の神になってしまってるんですね
もう随分役柄変わっちゃうんですね
だから元々シヴァっていうのは修行の神であって
モヘンジョダロとかね
以前文化の巨大文化の中では修行の形で作っていたんですね
だから現代信仰してるシヴァっていうのは裸で踊っている人相なんですね
だから全ての欲望の世界を作って
いわゆる現象の世界を作った神っていうふうに総称してになってるんですけど
だからどちらかとハッキリしない
もうごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ役柄変わっちゃうんですね
ヒンドゥー教の中は とにかくそういう色んな適当ないくつかの信仰はまとめてブラフマ信仰やらインドラの信仰やらパジャパティやら
よく仏典では出てくる役柄
そういう神々の名前を挙げて
その人々にはもう理解しようもないんだと
そのように解脱した心が何なのかと
その解脱した心を理解することが神々には無理
できないんだと だからその悟りっていうのはいかにレベル高いものかということはね
お釈迦様はこちらで言いたいところなんですね
神が偉いかブッダが偉いかというところではなくて
もう心さえも理解できないんだと
彼らにとって だから彼らがいないいないと言って喧嘩を売るんではなくて
色と信じているんだったらどうぞ自由にと
でも体に至ってもそんなに能力はないんだろうと
アナワセーサン だからもうアナワセーサンというのは
もう他の神々でも誰でももう関係なく
もう残りなく みんなに誰にも理解できませんよと
何が理解できないかというと
イダン ニッシタン タタハガタッサ ウィンニャーナ
タタハガタ この場合はタタハガタっていうのは如来であって
真理を体験した人って意味なんですね
タタっていうのは事実
真理なんですね タタハガタというのは事実を体験した人
如来っていうのはその意味で定義するんですね
だからこの真理を この事実を体験した人のウィンニャーナが
意識がイダン ニッシタン
このようなものである
ここにあるんだそうと
これに依存しているんだそうとかね
そういう引っ掛けっていうのは何一つもわからないんだと
ですから このニッシタンというのは何かに支えていてということで
ヴィンヤーナだから ヴィンヤーナっていうのは対象に支えられて生まれるんですね
我々は何か見て楽しいと思っちゃうと
その楽しみが見た対象に依存しているんですね
で ああ 今日はすごい楽しいやと思ったら
もしかすると音楽を聴いて楽しかったかもしれません
それで自分の楽しみという識が音楽というものに依存しているんですね
だからヴィンヤーナっていう意識がいつでも何かに引っかかって生まれるもので
独立して生まれることはありえないんです
全ては因果法則ですからね
因縁なしに何も生まれません
ですから ヴィンヤーナも因縁で生まれるんですから
いつでもヴィンヤーナ調べようと思ったら
因縁調べればわかるんですよ
もっとわかりやすく もっと例を言いますか
例えば上の三階で何か物を置いておきます
そこで人がそれを見て帰ってくる
その人がどんな気持ちでいるかは我々にはあまりわかりません
そこで私たちも三階に行ってみる
行ってみたら その同じものを見る
見ると私たちも何か心が気持ち変わるでしょ
見たところで そうすると
その対象に沿って あの人もおそらくこの気持ちになったでしょうということを推測できるんですね
ですから 例えばものすごいびっくりするものであるとしますね
それで自分もものすごいびっくりしたと
だったら前の人もおそらくびっくりしたんでしょうと
だから心はそうやって何か証拠から追ってみて理解するものなんですね
だからこの心はどこに支えられているかと
どんな対象に支えられているかということで
心の状況っていうのは見えてくるんですね
ですから イダン・ニッシタン・ヴィンヤーナ
心は何かに引っかかっているかということなんですね
だから 狙いの心は何に引っかかっているかって
これはさっぱりわからないんですね
だから証拠なし まるっきり
で 神々になんかは理解できませんと
タン・キッサ・ヘトゥ
それはなぜでしょうか
ディッテーワ・アハン・ビッキャヴェー・ダンメー・タターガタン・アナヌベッジョーティ・ヴァダーメー
ディッテーワ・ダンメー
ディッテーワ・ダンメーっていうのは
今ここにおいてもという
今ここでという意味です
狙いを理解できませんと
その場合はおそらくお釈迦様自身かもしれません
あるいは悟った他のお坊様方かもしれませんし
そこで生きているんだからね
お釈迦様自分で喋ってるんだから
ここに座って説法している狙い
ブッダがいると その今ここにいるブッダはどんなものかということさえも理解できないんだから
この解脱した心のこと理解
それはありえないんだと
だから誰にでもお釈迦様ってどんなものかということが理解できなかったんで
できないほど大きいんですね
だから狙いが生きていても
狙いのことは理解しがたい
知り難い 知り得ない 知り尽くすことは不可能な状態であって
これでお釈迦様亡くなったらどうするんでしょうか
お釈迦様の心はどんな状態でしょうかって
もう話にならないんだよということなんです
言ってるのは エワン・ワーディン・コー
私はこのように語っている
今までずっと経典を思い出してもらわないと
欲 性欲から始めて 徹底的に無我論をものすごい厳密に語り尽くして
これは人間に理解できないほどの大変な難しいことで
そこで全て実体がないんだから
一切現象としての存在の完全たる停止っていうことをお釈迦様は語っているんですね
それは言葉で理解できるものではないんですね
だからエワン・ワード
私はこのように語っているんだと
なのに エワン・アッカーイン
このように語っているのに
エーケー・サマナ・ブラフマナ
あるシャマン・バラモンたちが
ある宗教家たちが アサタ
ないことで トゥッチャ
根拠のない空っぽの言葉で
ムサ 嘘で アブーテーナ
なかったことで アッバーチッカンティ
罵ってるんだと 釈尊を罵している
批判しているんだと 批判している言葉は根拠のない空っぽな言葉で
あったこともない言葉で
言いたい放題のことを言って批判しているんだと
お釈迦様が批判している言葉は何なのかというと
ヴェーナイ・コー 一つお釈迦様はね
この何々主義者という風に名前を付けているんです
お釈迦様バカですよって
そういう風な品のない批判じゃないんですよ
これはもう哲学者の批判だから
宗教家の批判だから 罵りとかね
そんな低次元的ことではなくて
釈尊というのはウェーナイカですよと
ウェーナイカっていうのはいろいろ言葉でお釈迦様があんまり罵りてると思ってない時もあるし
本当に罵りてるんだよって言って怒鳴り散らしている時もあります
それはその時の気分次第で
人の質問次第でお釈迦様の答え変わりますけど
この場合 お釈迦様はかなり機嫌が良くないんですね
この場合 お釈迦様は実体論はもう壊しているところだからね
その時のウェーナイカの意味は違う言葉で取らなくちゃいけないと思いますけど
注釈書ではそう取ってないと思います
虚無論者でありと でも虚無論と言えば別な言葉があるんです
ナッティカワードー・サマナ・ゴータモーと
で ウェーナイカっていうのは虚無論ではないんですけど
この脈絡において虚無論として意味を取らなくちゃいけないんですね
で 虚無論という場合も
なぜウェーナイカという場合はあるものは壊すという意味です
その意味で破壊主義者なんです
だから破壊主義者ですね
虚無論よりも だから虚無論の場合は全く別な言葉なんです
ウェーナイカと言っちゃうと破壊主義なんです
このウェーナイカイコール破壊主義という場合も
この脈絡においての訳であって
他のところでは違う翻訳をしなくちゃいけないんです
だからこれヴィナヤから出てきている言葉で
ヴィ・ナヤという わざわざと反対の方向へ導くという動詞からできてるんですね
パーリ語でニーという動詞で
sanskritだったらネーでしょうと思いますけど
ナヤティという導くという言葉なんですね
だからヴィっていうのは反対方向へ
で 導く 行く 行くべき道では
あれ行ってる道ではなくて
反対の方に導く 違う方向へ導くということで
ヴィネーなんですね だから戒律
ヴィネーなんです なぜ戒律はヴィネーかというと
人々が行ってる方向ではなくて
違う方向へ導くんです
そっちではなくて こっちに行きなさいと
その故に戒律にはヴィネーという言葉は堂々と使ってるんですね
英訳する場合はディシプリンと訳しますけど
ディシプリンというよりはちょっと意味が強いんです
ディシプリンといえば
日本語で言えばしつけみたいなもので
しつけですよ だからしつけ論というよりはもっと違うんですね
だからヴィネーと言うんですね
ヴィネーというのは 人々が生きている生き方ではなくて
全く逆の道を案内するということです
だから当然ながらヴィネー
戒律と俗世間の生き方っていうのは違うんです
戒律を守っている生き方と守らない生き方っていうのは正反対
もう背を合わせている生き方なんですね
同じ-ないんです で 世俗的な生き方では
まあ欲は素晴らしいことで
欲があったら成功する
まあ怒りもいいことで
それで悪いものを敵を倒せる
っていうふうな生き方です
ですから 自分の都合が悪ければ本当のことを言ってはいけないんだと
やっぱり儲かるんだったら嘘を言ったってもいいんじゃないかというふうな
まあ普通の生き方で 普通の生き方ではとにかく世俗的に儲かることがメインにしてるんですね
ただもう楽しく食べて
まあ儲けて生きていて
死ぬことのともどうすればいいかと
それは普通の生き方 世俗的な生き方
で ヴィネーっていうのはそれの反対です
だからもともと生っていうのはまあ認めてない
だから戒律の場合は誰でもなんかいろいろまあ恨みを感じるかもしれませんだけど
生を認めてないんですよ
本体は どうやって金持ちになって
もう権力者になって 地球支配して生きていられるかと
そのための道ではなくても
反対の道を教えてるんですね
ですから戒律はそうなっているという
シーラっていうのは項目いう場合はよく使うんですね
項目いくつかあるかとかね
項目設定すると ヴィネーのために項目設定する場合はシーラと呼ぶんですね
例えば嘘をつくなよと言ったらシーラであって
嘘をつかないことがヴィネーであって
嘘をつかないことでよって
自分が世俗的な見方と違う生き方戒めているんですね
項目として受け取るとシーラなんですね
何が違うかと それでね
なんか分からないんですけど
だから五回守るか十回守るかとか聞く場合はパンチシーラかダサシーラかと言うんですね
そうすると項目五つか十個成り立ってるでしょうに
だから項目ごとに勉強する場合はシーラという
でもヴィネーは全て項目で扱えますかという
じゃあいくつかの項目立てたところで
人間の生き方は全てそれに入りますかね
そこは問題です だからシーラは増えたり減ったりする
ヴィネーは増えることも減ることもないんです
だからお釈迦様が亡くなる時でも
やっぱり細かい細かいことでもやめてしまえと
それは項目なんです ヴィネーやめてしまえということじゃないんです
まあ例えばインドの世界で高価な服で衣着てはいけないってことがあったとしましょう
当時ではもう大変なことだからね
そんな高価な服なんか調べちゃうともうかなりみんなに迷惑
そうすると 自分の贅沢のために
まあ自分が良ければいいんじゃないかという生き方になっちゃうんですね
それではダメでしょうし
たとえ自分が例えばお腹が減ってあっても
私はお腹が減ってるんだから何か食べ物をちょうだいと言ってはいけない
それは自分の都合 自分の生きることを正当化しない限りはできるわけじゃないんです
でも 世俗世界ではそんな悪くも何でもないんです
この人はものすごくお腹が減って食べてないんだから
ちょっと言ってもらった方が何が悪いんですかと
その場合は 食べることは正しくて
生き続けることは正しいんですね
出家の場合は 弟子たちは違うんだから
人からおねだりしてでも食って生き続けるべきものですかと
苦しみを続けるものですかと
ですから 生きることに性に価値を入れてないんで入れてはいけないんだから
それは戒律項目としてお願いしてはいけないと
願ってはいけない それは戒律
人に食べ物をねだるなよと
まあ項目 戒律 その裏にヴィネーがあるんです
それで現代世界では食べ物っていうのはどうったことない
一番もう単純でもありすぎ
相手にしたっても 誰か食べた方がありがたいことで
でなきゃもう捨てなくちゃいけないし
で それで今の時代でちょっとじゃあこれ私にちょうだいと言ったっても
別に相手に対して何の迷惑もないし
何のこともない ですから
今の時代になったらこの人にごはんねだるなよという戒律は別になくてもいいんです
それでもって大変なこの性に欲が生まれたということはない
ごはん食べる人にとってもどうったことはないし
あげる人にとってもどうったことはないし
ですから まあそうするとこの項目の価値が減っちゃうんですよ
戒律項目の価値が シーラの価値が減っちゃうんです
シーラの価値が減るんだけど
ヴィネーの価値が減りません
それは絶対です それもう理解するために結構考えなくちゃいかんですけどね
だからヴィネヤはもう絶対的な教えで真理で
シーラは絶対的ではなくて相対的で
具体的に気に払いませんですけど
仏教の場合 それはやっぱりしっかりしています
例えば人にヴィネヤがないと
あなたに何のヴィネヤもないんだよと叱ることはできますが
なんとか戒律破壊してるんだよと言って訴えることはできないんです
例えば項目の場合は 破ったら法律的に罰を与える
あんたはこの項目破ったんだよと
出家の中では ですから
破った項目にそれなりに決まってる罰の中で処理しなさいよと
ほとんど懺悔で終わりますけど
懺悔終わらない罰もあります
でも時々戒律全部守っているんだけど
ヴィネヤない人もいるんです
その場合はお坊さんは困っちゃうんですよ
訴えられないんです サンガの前で何々さんがこういう間違いを犯してるんだよと
その時は困っちゃうんです
だからヴィネヤと戒律
そういう二つ出ているんです
元々お釈迦様時代で六人のグループがいたんで
これ有名な六人なんですね
だからチャッバッゲといって
まあ六人のグループと
よくその言葉で言ってるんです
とにかく行儀が悪い なんとか変なことをする
いつでもお釈迦様が戒律項目作ったら
またそこ次から次とお釈迦様は戒律項目変えて変えていかなくちゃいけないんですね
変えていくんだけど お釈迦様の場合は増えるだけなんですね
お釈迦様も嫌でしたけどね
できるだけお釈迦様はシーラが少なくしたかったんです
ヴィネヤだけで良かったんですよ
でもなんか変なことしたらお釈迦様は戒律シーラ作るんです
それでその六人の人々っていうのは
お釈迦様は何かやってはいけないと
例えば出家は出家を殴ってはいけないと
と それシーラ で この六人が行って
この野郎殺してやるぞと言って殴らないんです
肋骨を折ってやるぞと
わざと喧嘩売るんです
肋骨折ってやるぞと言ってきて
殴るが全然殴れませんよ
戒律厳守しているんだから
それで気が弱いお坊さんたちは泣いちゃうんですね
怖くなっちゃって これ六人のヤクザみたいなグループだから
だからどうするもこつこつもできないんですよ
殴ったらすぐその場でもう法律を犯しちゃったんだから捕まります
捕まってお釈迦様は手を出しませんから
もうサンガの中で必ず有罪になるんです
有罪になるとそれなりのまたいろいろ決まりがあって
もう絶対そのお坊さんたちと付き合ってはいけないとか
あるいは誰ともあなた方と付き合ってはいけない
いろんな罰を決められます
あるいはこの地方から出ていけと
もう出て帰ってくるなよと追い出すことさえもできますけど
殴ってないんだからどうにもならん
でもね なんかどこかで納得いかないでしょ
だからヴィネヤがないんですよ
シーラはあるんです その職人のグループに
そこでお釈迦様に訴えたら
お釈迦様がシーラ破ってないんだからいいでしょう
しょうがないよって そこはもうないんです
それでお釈迦様は二番目のシーラ決めるんです
脅してもいけませんと
比丘が比丘を脅してもいけません
そうすると この人々はロッコスを殴ってやる
追ってやるぞと言わない
脅しだからね 違うことがある
いろいろ嫌味言ったりとかね
ちょっと何か 何かもうとにかくシーラに触れないようにはする
とにかくシーラに触れないようにして
もうとにかくそういうとんでもないもう悪事を働かすと
だからそのストーリーから
このヴィネヤのテキストでは
もうそのケースがね 明確に出ているのは
この我々にこの法律的に理解してもらうためなんで
皆様に関係ないんですけど
これで出家っていうのは結構法律には詳しいんですよ
それお釈迦様のおかげです
だから いとも簡単に仏教を勉強する人には法律家にはなれます
裏も表ももう何だかんだ項目見ただけで見えちゃうんです
こんな項目だったらこうやったらもう大丈夫やと
ですから この法律の場合はもう全く悪いことしてはダメです
この場合はもっと細かいでしょうしね
悪いことをする気持ちもなかったとは思いますけど
とにかく法律内のギリギリのところで何かふざけることをできないかというふうな考え方でしたからね
まあそういうことで二つになっていて
両方ちゃんと理解していかなくちゃいけない
ですから ヴィネヤ完成することは修行になりまして
戒律 シーラ完成することっていうのは完成したんだからって
まあそんなことないんです
大事なのはヴィネヤであってね
だからヴィネヤと智慧が一体になっていて
ヴィネヤっていうのはこの聖を乗り越えるための生き方であって
聖を乗り越えること自体はパンニャーで智慧であってという
まあ実践と論理の組み合わせなんですね
だから実践がヴィネヤなんですね
だからヴィネヤといえば瞑想もヴィネヤに入るんですけど
シーラには入りません
シーラは項目守ることだからね
それはもう守ってからヴィネヤに入らなくちゃいけない
まあとにかくヴィネヤっていうのは
そういうふうに この聖の反対のことを言っている
聖を乗り越えること 脱出することを教えている道ですからね
ですから そういうことで生きることを釈尊が否定しているではないかと
だからヴィネヤって ここで破壊というふうにその人々は理解しているんですね
他の宗教家が だから破壊するためにはあるものがなければいけないんですね
だから彼らが人がいるんではないかと
魂 霊魂あるんではないかと
これね あるのにも生命がいるにも関わらず
釈尊が破壊主義を掲げているんだと
魂を永遠になるように何かしようではなくて
潰せと壊せと言ってるんではないかと
この尊い魂を 永遠な魂を
まあ日本で知ってる言葉で言えば
仏性を発見するんじゃなくて
潰せ 壊せ 殺せと なんて残酷な言葉ではないかと
で 日本仏教ではこの仏性という言葉が出てあって
それはもうヒンドゥー教のがその同じ考え方が仏教としては我取った人たちは格好悪いんだから仏性にしちゃったんですね
だからなんか仏性になってしまっちゃったんですけど
仏性になりまして 結局もう哲学的に見ればヒンドゥー教の神我と同じものなんですけど
で お釈迦様の立場から見れば
仏性あるかって言っちゃうと
もう追い出すしか方法ないんですね
もうあんた何言うんでしょうかと
で そんなね ありがたいものっていうのは何一つもないという立場をとっているんで
全て無常だと あると思ってるんだったら
まあそれ壊さなくちゃいけないんですね
だから別にお釈迦様仏性を壊せ
神我壊せと言ってるわけじゃないんです
神我は見いだせないんだよと
調べても調べても全て無常の現象のみやと
見なさいよと どこにあるかと
全くサッチャとテータとアヌパラッビエマーネ
真理として 実体として
具体的に見いだせないにも関わらずという
ものすごい明確な言葉で言ってるんですね Fact
as a fact as a reality, as a substance という
我々が訳する場合はね
という我が見いだせないんだと
だから億トンぐらいの土の中でも
一粒の金でもあれば とにかく苦労して億トンの土も洗って洗って洗って洗って
この一粒の金を見つかってもいいんですけど
それぐらいでもあるんだったらいいんだよとおっしゃってやったでしょうね
この同じ経典で でも調べても調べてもないんだったらどうしますかね？なんで潔くないと決めないんですかね
それで実体が見いだせないだけであると
お釈迦様は実体壊せと殺せと潰せという破壊塾語ってるわけじゃないんです
だからお釈迦様は破壊主義者と言った途端
もう全く根拠のないとんでもないインチキ嘘の侮辱なんですよ
誹謗なんです 頭のいい人の考え方ではないんですね
だからお釈迦様はその時点ではベーネクで言っちゃうと
ものすごくこれは誹謗やと言ってるんです
他のところでお釈迦様が出て
ブラマジで あんたね 本当にベーネクですね
まあそういえばそういうふうに言えないわけでもないんだよと
だって私は怒りなくせと欲なくせと無知なくせと言うんだからね
まあ根拠はありますよと認めるんです
からかいながらも だからその場合によります
そういう なんでその時親切に冗談で相手の誹謗を認めるかというと
やっぱりその人も結局お釈迦様を誹謗したいという気持ちではなくて
対話しているんですよ
対話っていうのは知りたくて成り立つもので
この対話の場合はそうやって批判というのは当然出てくるんです
あんた言うことはベーネクではないかと
本人知りたいんですね
誹謗してるわけじゃないんです
そういう批判でも その時お釈迦様はものすごく心広く
それは受け止める 受け止めて相手にぶん殴ることではなくて
まあそう考えちゃうとね
そういう立場がありますよと
だって私はこういう悪を壊せと
悪をもう壊滅しなさいと言ってるんだから
そのポイントで見ると
壊滅主義 破壊主義というのは悪くないんだよといったところで
本人がお釈迦様壊滅主義ではなくて
悪を壊すと言ってるだけではないかと
そこら辺ではまあいいんじゃないかという同感をしてもらうんですね
この場合はまた立場が違いますから
実体がないという無我論を徹底的に語ったところだから
誹謗中傷です その場合はベーネクという言葉が
だからサトーサッタス
いる生命の 存在する生命の
実体としてある生命のウッチェーダン
壊滅 破壊を ヴィナーサン
破壊を ウッチェーダン
ヴィナーサン ヴィバワン
もうないことをパンニャペー
教えているのだ いわゆる
ある 実体としてある生命の破壊することを壊すこと
潰すことを教えているのではない
ヤッターワーハンビッキャヴェーナヤターチャハンナヴァダーミ
タターマンテーブントーサマナブラフマナアサタアトゥッチャーメサアブーテーナアッバーチッカンティ
ヤッターワアハンビッキャヴェーナ
私はそういうふうなことを言ってるわけじゃないでしょうと
ヤターチャハンナヴァダーミ
私はそんなこと言ってもないんだと
生命がある ある生命壊せと言ってないんだよと
私は言ってないんだと
タターマンテーブントー
それなのに言ってないことを言ったと勘違いして
私を誹謗しているんだと
ベーネクサマナブータマ
それでお釈迦様は誹謗否定するんですね
私はそんなこと言ってない
サトーサッタッサ サトーサマーノ・サッタッサ・ウッチェダン・ヴィナーサン・ヴィブーワン・パンニャ・ペンティとかね
まあそういうとこは言ってないんだと
だから この変に勉強する人々はこのところだけ取っちゃうと
サトー・サッタッサ・ヴィブーワン・ヴィナーサン・パンニャ・ペンティというところは
私はこのようなこと言ってないんだとはっきり言ってます
そんなこと 言ってないんだいとそれだけ引用して
故にお釈迦様はサトー
エキスタンス 私たち英語で勉強しちゃったんだからしょうがない
英語ではそういう意味ある言葉なんで
サブスタンス エキスタンス
ソウルというのはね だから実体は
生命の実体がないと 実体ある生命の破壊っていうのは言ってないんだと
言ったところで やっぱりお釈迦様は実体認めてるんだよと
実体ある生命の破壊まで言ってないんだから
というふうに また実体論を蘇しちゃうということもあるんです
どうせ仏教では実体論が蘇ってしまったし
研究論文などなどにももう何のことなく実体論を蘇してもらう
でも全部学問的にもおかしくて間違ってるんですけどね
それでお釈迦様は じゃあお釈迦様は何をおっしゃるんでしょうかと
パンニャ・ペンティっていうのは
これはこの通りですという
このものはこのものですと
はっきりと明言するもの
ただ 地球は丸いですということははっきりした明言なんですね
言った人が認めなくちゃいけない
そうではなかろうか ああではなかろうかという
この意見を述べているわけじゃなくて
ちゃんとした結論を出す
故に これこれですという
パンニャ・ペンティという言葉は
その意味なんです お釈迦様が
これこれですと はっきりと何を明言したんですかと
結論出したんですかと
発表したんですかと お釈迦様は
プッベーチャ・アハン・ビッケー・エータライ
昔も今も私は ドゥッカンチャ・パンニャ・テーミ・ドゥッカッサチャ・ニローダン
私たちは全部そこら辺は暗記していますけどね
仏教哲学においては大変大事なところでね
だから プッベーチャ・アハン・エータライ・ドゥッカンチャ・パンニャ・テーミ・ドゥッカ・ニローダンって
私はずっと一貫して 悟った時からずっと一貫してドゥッカン
ドゥッカということをしっかりと結論出している
生命ではなくて お釈迦様はドゥッカという言葉を使っている
それのそれなりのちゃんと定義もある
次にドゥッカッサチャ・ニローダン
このドゥッカのニロード
消えること なくすこと
教えているんですから
決して教無主義者ではないんですよ
苦しみをなくすことをおっしゃっているんだから
懐疑主義でもないんです
虚無主義でも懐疑主義でもないんです
本当は幸福を語ってます
でも魂の幸福とかなんとか
そういうくだらない話ではないんです
生命はドゥッカであると
ドゥッカであるからこそドゥッカをなくすべきですよというふうに
すごく鋭く言葉を使って語っているんです
生命はなくすべきですよと言ったら
これちょっと大胆な言葉で疑問起きやすい
ドゥッカをなくすべきですと言ったら
別に誰もそれに反対しませんだから
調べてみたらドゥッカ何なのかというと ＝
生命なんですけど それもお釈迦様言わない
何がドゥッカだと 色受想行識がドゥッカであると
色受想行識は人間が生命として誤解しているだけ
その誤解にはもう立ち下がらない
ですから 色受想行識という五蘊がある
その五蘊が無常である
それ故にドゥッカである
ドゥッカのなくすこと
私は語っている えーと
タ
トラ・チェ・ビッケーヴェ・パレー・タターガタ・アッコーサンティ・パリバーサンティ・ローセンティ・タトラ・ビッケーヴェ・タターガタッサ・ナホーティ・アー
ガート・ナ・アッパッチャヨ・ナ・チェータソー・アナヴィラッティ
そこでタトラ・チェ それなのに
まるっきり無知でお釈迦様に対してね
ビッケー・パレー 他人が
タターガタ・アッコーサンティ
お釈迦様を アッコーサンティ何でしたっけ
罵る パリバーサンティ
もっと激しく罵ること
パリバーサンティなんですけど
それからローセンティ
怒る 怒る いわゆるこの誹謗することはパーリ語で三つの言葉で言ってるんですね
アッコーサンティっていうのはすごく悪口を言うんですよ
この野郎とかなんとかとかね
パリバーサンティっていうのはものすごく貶して
もうバカにしてやる ローセンティっていうのはものすごく怒って怒る
怒るって言葉 怒らせようとする
で 本人が怒ることなんですけど
結局 いわゆるこの誹謗は三つの言葉で言ってるだけのこと
文脈的な言葉です そういうふうなことを罵っても
貶されても 私に批判 非難しても
タトラ・ビッケーヴェ・タターガタッサ・ナホーティ・アーガート
もう釈迦様は全然 アーガート
全然怒り持ってないんだと
そんなことで アッパッチョ
ちょっと機嫌が悪くなって全然ないんだと
アッパッチョでなんか都合が悪くなると
なんかまずいと思っちゃうとかね
こんなこと言われるとちょっとまずい
全然ないんだと ナ・チェータ・ソウ・アナビーラ・ティ
心が不満になることもないんだと
嫌な気持ちになることもないんだと
怒るどころか ああ こんなこと言ったら都合が悪い
どうしようどうしよう
なんかちょっとということもないし
心で嫌な気持ちもないんだよと
もうどうぞ勝手にやってくださいと
すごい態度はあるんです
それでタットリ・チェータ・ビッケーレ・パレー
他人がお釈迦様にサッカロんて尊敬する
ガルカロンってそれも尊敬する言葉なんです
マーネーってものすごく尊敬する
プージェントっていうのは幼いまでするという
拝んだり尊敬したり 敬意を払ったり
もう全部言葉を扱っているんです
どのようにお釈迦様に拝んだり
供養したり 尊敬したりしたっても
タットリ・ビッケーレ・タターガタ・メホーティ
アーナンダ 別に私が喜ぶことはないんだと
機嫌がいいとかね 楽しいとかね
みんなに拝まれてないんだと
ナ・ソウ・マナッサン
全然喜びも感じませんと
ナ・チェータ・サウ・ウッビラ・アビタッタン
心は舞い上がることは全くないんだと
私が喜ぶこともないし
楽しくもないし 別に舞い上がることもないんだよと
けなされたんだからといって落ち込みもないし
舞い上がることもなんなんもないんだと
全然気にしていない 人のこと
タットラ・ビッケーレ・タターガタ・エワン・ホーティ
褒められると尊敬されると
お釈迦様はこのように考えるんだそうです
ヤンコ・イダン・プッベー・パリニャータン・タッタメー・エーヴァ・ルーパ・カーラ・カリーヤンティー
ヤンコ・イダン・ビッケーレ・イダン・プッベー・パリニャータン
ああ これは私は前はね
何か獲得したこと 得たものがあるんだから
みんなそれでもって今尊敬しているんだぞと
パリニャータンというのは知った
終わったということで
悟りのことなので 私はもう前でちょっと先
すべて悟ってしまったんだからね
みんなそうやって尊敬しているんだぞと
自分という気持ちがないんですね
悟ったんだからやっているでしょうと
悟らなかったらそんなことやらないんだから
だから自分を褒めるという気持ちがないんですね
すごいわかりやすく言えば
総理大臣でいるときはみんな尊敬する
もうちゃんと警察も時間警備もしてくれる
どこに行っても SP がついてるとかね
それで舞い上がったらバカなんですよ
総理でいる時だけなんですね
大臣格がもうなくなっちゃうと
もう全部パーッて消えちゃいますからね
そんな気持ちで総理大臣という人は全然気にしない
みんなパス席から来ると
きちんと行く前に全部チェックもする
周りはちゃんと SP がついている
ボディーガードが 俺って偉いと思わないんです
思ったらアホなんです
それはもう総理だからやってくれるんであって
総理がなくなっちゃったらもう全然全部消えてしまいますね
そんな感じでお釈迦さんは僕
これ悟ったんだからやっていることだよっていうことで
すごい気楽にいているんですね
タスマーティヒャ・ビッケーレ・トゥンメー・チェーティ・パレー・サッカル・アアッコセイユン
パリバセイユン ローセイユン
タトラ トゥンニヒ ネ アガート
ネ アッパッチョー ネ チェーテソー
アナビラッビ カラニーヤ
それでお釈迦様は弟子たちにも同じことを戒める
だから君たちに対しても
人が叱ったり 罵ったり
誹謗したり 貶したりしちゃうと
怒ってはあかんぞと 君たちも
あんた方に対して人々が尊敬したり
拝んだり 供養したりしたっても
喜んだあかんと 舞い上がってはあかんと
もしあんた方にも人々が一生懸命拝んだり尊敬したりすると
そう思えない それはもうあんた方は何か修行して
何か心の安らぎ 体験しているならば
まあそれだからやってるんであって
でなきゃ誰も気にしないよと
だからこの解脱した心を大事に考えなさいということかな
で そこでそのポイントは終わります
で もうこの経典というのはものすごい難しくて
かなり厳密にギュウギュウとセッティングしていて
ポイントごとにかなりの量のことを言っちゃうんですね
だから経典の原義になったことというのは
もうひとかけらもなく
もう最初に消えちゃったんです
もうあいつは放っておけと
君たちにさせるぞと そこでお釈迦様はもう徹底的にまとめてお話をしちゃったんですね
次のポイントは この無我をお釈迦様は修行する人々に
この無我を体験するためのもうちょっとしたキーワードなんです
すっごい大事なキーワードなんですよ
悟り開けちゃったらければ
このキーワードをものすごい大事に思えないと
タスマーティヒャ・ビッケーヤン・トゥンハーカン・タン・パジャハタ
これも私たちは一応暗記する行なんです
ヤン・トゥンハーカン・タン・パジャハタ
まあそれぐらい大事な言葉なんです
タスマーティヒャ だからビクラよ
もうここまでお話をして
ヤン・トゥンハーカン
君らのものでないものが何かあるならば
タン・パジャハタ それ捨てなさいよと
これは私に入れ替えて言えば
私のものでないならば
それ持ち込むな 持つなよと
持っていくなよと 私のものじゃないんだから
他人のものだから まあ私って言うならばね
そこは言っちゃうと論理的に間違いますが
そうは言ってないんですね
だから あなた方のものでないものをパジャハタ
捨てなさいよと タンゴー・パヒーナン・ディーガラッタン・ヒタエ・スカエ・バビストティ
それを捨てた方が ディーガラッタンというのは長い間ということで
永遠という言葉を仏教はあんまり使わないんだから
この意味なんですよ 続く
ずっとあなた方の幸福になるんだよと
だから自分のものでないものを持っちゃうと
これ大変なことになります
でしょ 自分のものでないものには触れないようにしちゃうと
何の危険もなく幸せでいられる
まあそれだけはキーワードで
それからお釈迦様の注釈
キンキョ・ビッケーナ・トゥンハーカン
何が君らのものではないんでしょうかと
ルーパン・ビッケーナ・トゥンハーカン
ルーパがあなた方のものではありませんよ
ルーパというのはこの体ですよ
物体ですよ あなたのものじゃないんだよ
タン・パジャハタ 物体捨てなさい
タンゴー・パヒーナン・ディーガラッタン・ヒタエ・スカエ・バビストティ
私の体 私の体と捨てなさいよと
捨てたところですごい楽になるんだと
それはもう修行はかなり進んでいないとこの意味がわからないと思います
人間というのは苦しんでいるのは私の体と思っているんだからなんですか
なるそれだ 私の体 だったら一生苦しめということになるんです
体は苦しみしか作らないんだから
どんどん消えていくでしょうし
衰えていくでしょうに
やがて壊れて死ぬでしょうに
じゃあ悩めと 限りなく
だったら捨てなさいよと
あなたのものじゃないんだよと
捨てた方が楽ですよと
ウェーダナー・ビッケーナ・トゥンハーカン
それで体で感じるもの
痛いやら楽しいとかね
気持ちいいとか それあなたのものじゃないんだよと
だって私の楽しみじゃないでしょうに
何かものによって楽しみが勝手に生まれただけでしょうに
何か音が耳に入っちゃうと勝手に楽しくなっちゃうんであって
楽しみが私のものっていうことにならないんですね
音楽の代わりに雑音が流れちゃうと気持ち悪いんだから
そうすると嫌な気持ちが生まれるし
音楽が流れるといい気持ちが生まれるし
だから感覚は私のものじゃないんですよ
好き勝手なんですよ ご飯食べて美味しいかまずいかと感じるっていうことは
自分好き勝手にできるものじゃないんですね
だから味も勝手なものじゃないんですよ
他人の依存しているものなんで
食べ物に依存しているんですね
それから体の物体にも依存しているんです
ですから 美味しいっていうことは私のものってならないんだ
だからウェーダナーは私のものではない
捨てなさい 捨てた方が楽ですよと
それからサンニャ サンニャっていうのは
私は最近概念という風に訳してるんですからね
いっぱい頭の中に染み込んでいる
いろいろと概念という知識とかね
そういうもの 私のものではないんですよ
みんな誤解している 自分の知識が自分やと
そうじゃないんで 知識も外からもう勝手に入るものであって
物に自分が触れると知識が生まれるんであって
でなきゃ生まれないでしょうに
それで生まれた知識もどんどん消えていくでしょうに
だから因縁によるものであって
独立したものじゃないんです
哲学の本を読んで音楽の知識が得られますかね？私は音楽の知識を得たい
だから何でもいいんだから読んでみようと思ったって
それはできませんよ 音楽の知識を得たければ
音楽の練習したり 本を読んだりしなくちゃいけない
歴史の知識を得たければ
歴史の本を読んだりしなくちゃいけない
もう決まってるんです
だから私のものじゃないんですよ
食べ物の美味しさと同じく
外の世界との関わりによって生まれる現象なんですね
それまた無常でしょうしね
だからヴィンヤーナもサンニャーもあなたのものではありませんと
だからこの瞑想する場合はね
本当に自分のサンニャーに対して
これはもう全く客観的な他人のものだと
別に客観視して見るということのを言っているのは
主観で見ちゃうとダメ
だからお釈迦様の言葉は主観
客観ではなくて そういうすごい俗っぽい言葉なんで
すごいわかりやすい言葉でしょ
私が客観 主観使ってるんだから
なんかちょっと哲学っぽくて
みんなは喜んでいるんだけど
本当に気持ちいい言葉じゃないんです
そんなかっこつけてる言葉っていうのは
やりたくない人にとってはすごいかっこいい言葉ばっかりバンバン言わなくちゃいけない
できるだけパーリ語ばっかり使った方がみんな喜ぶと思います
私はずっともうルーパ
ウェーダナー サンニャーとかね
もうシーラ サマーディ
パンニャーとか もう何とか何とかとか使った方が
みんなすごい勉強してるお坊さんやとか
それだけでみんな愚か者
バカやってことを知ってるんだから
それは慈悲を持ってできるだけ俗語で
日常生活で使ってる日本語で仏教を語ろうとしてるんです
それは大変厳しいことなんですけど
それは慈悲でもってやってるんだけど
それに私を侮辱すること
いろいろ人々が 私に酔って勝ってしまおうと思って
もうバンバンパーリ語を使ったりとかね
わかってないということは若い頃からわかってるんですけど
対立したくたっても相手になれないんだから
もう黙ってるしか方法ないしね
まあそれがお釈迦様にしたってね
そんなペラペラ専門用語なんか使ってないんです
一応 色受想行識っていうのはみんなにすごい単純でわかったもんなんです
だから使っていたんです
すぐ一発でみんなわかるんですよ
色と言った途端 受と言った途端
サンニャーと言った途端
ウェーダナーと言った途端
すぐわかるんです だから使っていたんです
だから色受想 ルーパ ウェーダナー
サンニャー サンカーラにしても
やっぱりものすごい頭痛いほどの哲学的な解釈ってのはよくないんです
そうすると何がなくすかというと
悟りがなくしちゃうんです
その代わりにくだらない知識
新しいサンニャーが生まれて
俺が知ってるんだぞということで
さらに新しい煩悩が生まれるだけ
お釈迦様の狙いと全く正反対でしょうに
仏教を勉強したことで
よくブッダのことを理解したことで
私はもっと高慢になったぞと
もっと凶暴になったぞと言ってたでしょうに
意味がないんですね だからもう煩悩を捨ててほしいんです
ですから できるだけ即物的
即合で できるだけ一般人の言葉で
自分が本当に理解できる創極的な言葉で勉強しなくちゃいけないんですね
頭の中でそんな難しい哲学的な用語を使っているはずがないと思いますけど
使っているならば頭が悪いと思います
私は寸地に物事を分析する秘密は
ものすごい単純に考えてるからなんです
もう想像を絶するほどの単純に考えるんです
私の脳の中だったら もう小学生一年生にも理解できる
それぐらい単純に考える
で もうじゃあ当たってみてください
誰が勝てるか カントがそう言いましたとか出てきたら
私の一言葉で潰れてしまいます
だからこの頭の悪さっていうのは
そうやって借りた概念で見栄張ってもうからくりしているんだから
本物じゃないんです 本物の心っていうのはすごい単純で
機能しているんです だからヴィパッサナーでそこは発見できるんですよ
だから一応日本語として難しい言葉ではないんだから主観
客観という言葉を使ってますけど
それも大乗仏教でよくよく使った言葉で
サンスクリット語で仏教が取り入れになったところで
やっぱりこのカーラナカーラかとかね
カーラカーラかとかね
すごい哲学的な難しい言葉できちゃったんだからね
で 唯識もね いっぱいそんなもの使ったりね
知るもの知られるものとかね
それで結局悟りがなくなっただけなんですけどね
お釈迦様はあんたのものでないものを捨てなさいよと
何が君のものではないかというと
この物体が君のものじゃないでしょう
捨てなさいと言って 単純な人だったら
小学生一年生ぐらいの知恵のある人だったら
俺のものじゃないかと見るだけで
それで客観的に見られるんですよ
この考え方は これも自分のものじゃないね
そこで無執着の心が寸地に生まれるんですね
この痛みも この悲しみも
これもまあ勝手に外のことやと
この認識も あ これも勝手に悪いことで
自分のものじゃないと
だってどこに自分があるんでしょうか
何もないんだろうと という楽を感じちゃいますよ
だから子供でも悟ったケースっていうのはそういうわけなんです
子供にできて大人にできないことだからね
で そこでサンカーラ サンカーラっていうのはこの生まれてくる衝動ですね
何かやりたくてやりたくてたまらんという衝動
いつも持ってるでしょうに
ご飯食べたい 座りたい
歩きたい 寝たいとかね
常に一秒一秒でも 一秒の百分の一でも
何とかしたいという衝動っていうのはあるんです
ただ それ私ですかというと
そうじゃないでしょうね
衝動もぐるぐると変わるんだから
外の勝手でしょうに こちらに生まれてくる衝動も外の勝手なんです
だから自分のものじゃないんです
サンカーラ 次に認識そのもの
ヴィンヤーナっていうのはね
そんなものはあなたのものではない
ですから捨てなさい 捨てた方が長い間楽になりますよと
で それで教えたんです
それだけで止まらない
もっと即物的に お釈迦様がもっと一般人のレベルにこの話を持ってくるんですね
たとえを持ってくるんです
たとえ見てください サンキンマンニヤタビッラウェ
あなた方はどう思いますか
ヤンイマスミンジェタワネ
ティンナカッタサーカーパラサン
タンジャノハレイエワ
ダヘイエワ ヤタアパッチャンワカレイエ
君たちどう思いますか？このジェータワナというこのジェータワナ精舎に大きな建物ではなくてね
大きな公園でしたからね
たくさんティナ 草ありますね
カッタというのは薪ですね
サーカーというのは枝
大きな枝 パラサっていうのはおそらく小さな枝でしょうね
そこでいっぱい木があるんだから
また草もあるんだだから人々来て
その草を取って持っていく
枝を持っていく 薪のためにね
葉っぱも拾って持っていくとかね
持っていくでしょう ハレイエ
持っていく あるいはまとめてダヘイエ
燃やす ヤタアパッチャンが適当にいろいろなことをする
掃除をして 枯れ葉をまとめて燃やすとかね
枝なんかあったら それは全部まとめて燃やすか
誰かがそれを薪の代わりに持っていくとか
そうするとアピルトゥンマアカンイランガタ
あなた方こういうふうに思いますかと
アンヘージャノーハランテ
人々が私を私たちを連れて行くんだぞと思いますか？ああ
私を連れて行くんだとか思いますか？ああ
大変だとか 私を燃やしてるんだ
どうしよう どうしようかと思いますか？私を好き勝手なことをやらせるんだと私に思いますか？ノーヘーさん
そんなこと思いません
ただのゴミだからね ただのゴミを燃やしてるんだから
私を燃やしてると思わないでしょうということ
だから私はこのゴミという言葉をこちらから取っているんです
ゴミ論はね それは別に乱暴な言葉言ってるわけでも
日本の文化を侮辱して壊してるわけでもないんです
無価値論もゴミ論も全部もうきちんと経典に基づいて喋ってるんです
この経典引用しちゃうと
みんな偉そうに勉強して私に知ったかぶりするんだから
一度も言わなかったんです
知ったかぶりをしてほしくない
もう知られてるんだから
心安らげにしてほしい
心の煩悩をなくしてほしい
ですから もうバンバンと言っただけのことなんです
だから皆さんはもう本当にお釈迦様そんなこと言ったっけと疑いながら話を聞いたならば
正直にその話に則って聞いたならば
心は明らかになるはずでしたけどね
で 例えばね 体も全部ゴミだと
ただの生ゴミだと堂々と言ってるでしょうに
そこで聞くところでは
この人の口調だと それはスマナサーラの言い方やということで処理しちゃうんですね
それで私は決してスマナサーラの口調で言ったわけじゃなくて
お釈迦様の口調を借りただけね
注釈書は借りません それスマナサーラ節ではなかったんです
先生 ブッダの言い方なんです
だからいかに強く いかに迫力あったかっていうことね
生ぬるくはないんです
また さらに私もきついんだから
結構柔らかくするんですよ
人の前で言えないほどのきついことを言いますから
お釈迦様が だからそれはやっぱりこの欲を捨てるために
そういうふうにおっしゃっていて
だからこちらはきちんとこの体そのものがゴミという
ゴミですと ちゃんと もっと具体的に
もっとわかりやすく もっと実践的に見えてるんだから
人々はゴミを燃やすは
ゴミを持っていくは いろいろなことで
お坊さんたちは何のことなくいるんだから
このように ルーパ・ウェーダナー・サンニャー・サンカーラ・ヴィンニャーナについても
色・受・想・行・識についても
そういうふうに思いなさいと
タン・キッサ・ヘーと
なぜならば ナヒノー・エータン・バンテ・アッターワ・アッタニーワと
なぜかというと お釈迦様はこれは私でもないし
私のものでもないと その場合はアッタという我という言葉を使うんですね
エーワ・メーワコー・ビッケーワ・ヤンガ・トゥンマカーン・タンパジャーと
そのように君らのものでないものを捨てなさいと捨てる論を教えるんです
タンオーパヒーナンディーガラタンヒタイスカエバヴィッサティ
キンチャビッケーナトゥンマハカ
何が君らのものではないかといえば
ルーパとヴェーダナーとサンニャーカンカーラウィニャーナという五取が君らのものではありません
そこで エワンスワッカートービッケーマヤダンマ
私はこのように正しく語っているんだよ
スワッカートー  ウェルバースというか
正しくきちんと発言しているんだ
ガタガタじゃない しっかりとぴったしと
聞いたら悟れる まだ反論もできない
成り立たない 疑問は生まれません
どれほど気をつけて喋ったかという
例えば生命は亡くなった方がいいやとか
そんなこと言ったら疑問生まれるでしょうに
それは言ってない ドゥッカは亡くなった方がいい
だから生命とか我とかそんなものを使わないでドゥッカ
私は昔も今もドゥッカのこと
ドゥッカを滅することだけ語ってるんだ
そういう言葉選びのところから
ものすごい厳密に 微かにでも疑問が生まれないようにしっかりと語っているのに
なんで仏教を壊したんでしょうかということ
これはもう 本当にどうにもならんですよ
スワッカートービッケーマヤダンマウッターノ
はっきりと上に出してみてるんです
ウィワトー オープンにしているんです
パカアシとみんなに公示というか公表しているんです
発表している パカアシの発表です
チンナピローとこの布を破っているんです
それはもう昔の言葉で
昔何かものを持っていくと
布で 日本でもそうでしょう
布で何か被せてというかね
包装して持っていくんですね
それで見えないんですね
それを破っているんです
中身は見えるんです まあそれで
まあそこで全部経典の結論に言っていますけど
エワンスワッカートービッケーマヤダンメー
このように私ははっきりと説明している時
ウッターネヴィワテーパカアシテチンネピローティケ
全部破って みんなにオープンにしているんだから
イエーテービックー 誰か比丘がアラハントー
阿羅漢になる キーナハサオー
無漏 煩悩なくなった状態になる
ブッシテワントー 修行終わった人になる
カタカラニーヨ 成すべきことはなし終えた人になる
オーヒテバーロ 重荷を下ろした人になる
アヌッパッタサダッタ
真理に達した人になる
パリッケーナバワサンヨージャナ
生き続けたい生き続けたいというあの衝動がもう滅した
消えた人になっている
サッマダンニャービムッタ
正しく智慧で解脱をしている
その人にワッタン 回転ということ
ずっとやりたい やりたい
やりたい 何かしたい したいという
その回転 輪廻ですね 輪廻
テーサンナッティパンニャーパナイ
輪廻は見いだすことはできません
この人もまだ回転するそうと
ありえないなと だからパンニャーパナイという言葉はまたすごい大事な言葉で
我々は輪廻がなくなったんだというと
そういうないということで理解しちゃうでしょうね
お釈迦様はパンニャーパナという言葉なんですね
だから日本語でもう成り立たない
見いだせないという風にしか言えないんですね
成立しないと 輪廻 回転というのは成立しない
輪廻がなくなった 消えた
なんかあるべきものが消えたような
なんか損したような気がしますけど
お釈迦様はそういうわずかな気がもしないように
ね パンニャーパナイ 成り立たない
見いだせない 成立しないという言葉を使っているんですね
輪廻は成立しないと そこで
パンチャオーランバーギヤーニサンヨージャナニパヒーナニ
もしお釈迦様の説法を聞いて
五つのカ分カケツですか
あの十結がありますから
輪廻に我々束縛されている煩悩が五つありまして
順番で最初は五つ壊しちゃうんですね
最初ではなくて この不還果になると五つ壊されているんです
だから十個もなくなったら阿羅漢
全部なくなったら 五つなくなったら不還果なんです
サッベーテーオーパパーティカ
彼らがオーパパーティカっていうのは
この自動的に生まれ変わっちゃうんですね
死んじゃったらすぐどこかに
まあ浄土 仏教では浄土という言葉を使ってますけど
まあそれ日本で言ってる浄土ではないんです
梵天ですけどね 梵天にさっと現れちゃうんですね
タッタパリニッバーナイノ
そこで涅槃に入る 残りの五つなくなって
そこで涅槃に入る 戻りません
アナワティダンマ 帰ってこない
不還です タスマーローカ
その生まれた梵天からはいかなる場合でも落ちることはなし
一旦上へ上がったらそこからニルヴァーナ
これは不還果の状態 そこでこのような私の説法を聞いて
もし比丘がティーニサンヨージャナニパヒーナ
サンヨージャナ 煩悩が三つなくなったならば
それはこの有身見と疑と戒禁取ですね
その三つなくなったならば
なくなっただけじゃなくてラーガドーサモーハタヌブータ
ラーガ 欲と怒りと無智がタヌブータ
すごく薄くなっている
あの三つの煩悩も綺麗になくなっているだけではなくて
その上ラーガドーサモーハ
貪瞋痴がすごく薄くなっているならば
サッベーテサカダーガーミノ
一回帰ってくる サキデーワイマンローカンアガントワ
一回だけ人間の世界に戻ってくる
ドゥッカサンタンカレスグ
もう悟ってしまうと そういう人もまあまあ今現在見当たらないかも
いるかもしれませんしね
もう人間調べることできませんだからね
生まれてもやっぱり無常は知っている
実体論にはなかなか行かない
もう因果法則はちゃんと身についているとかね
それで欲はすごい少ない
性に執着はしない でもすぐ出家して
もうそのまま終わってしまっちゃうという
生まれつきそういう清らかな心で生まれてくる聖者がいます
それでそれは三番目 エワンスワカーテビクエマーダン
このように私はした説法を聞いた人々が
イエサンビクウナンティーニサンヨージャナニパヒーナニ
この有身見 実体がないことと
疑と 疑っていうのは因果法則に対する疑ですね
それから戒禁取っていうのは
いろんな儀式儀礼に対する執着なんですね
呪文唱ならば悟るんだとかね
滝行したら悟るんだとかね
護摩焚いたら悟るんだとかね
というこの徹底した煩悩
日本でも真宗宗教一つあるでしょ
もう解脱供養というものまであるんです
火を焚いてそれで解脱するんだとかね
千祖解脱供養とかね たくさん火を焚いて
もうそれで解脱供養するんだとかね
だからどこまで仏教から脱出してて仏教の名乗っているかというとね
キリスト教よりひどいんですね
だから仲良くするならば
キリスト教の人々はイスラム教と仲良くする
何のことないんです ハッキリしているのは
向こうは神を見る これは信じないだけで
でも構成的にいっぱいありました
私でもかなりイスラム教の人々
かなりイスラム教批判的なんですけど
個人的には結構仲良くしてるんです
なぜならば その人はすごい道徳的で
すごい生き方しっかりしていて
そこら辺ですぐもう接点見つかるんですよ
日本にいる友達のイスラムの人々でも
他の人々は自分家に呼びたくないんですね
私だったらもうバンバン来て来てちょうだいと
すぐもう来てもらっちゃうとかね
それで来てもいろいろもう
お断り文句ばっかりですみませんとかなんとかとかね
まあどうか気に入るかわからないんでしょうとかね
料理作ったっても まあこういう風に作りましたけど
それでよろしいでしょうかとかね
すごい基本だからやっぱり生き方はその辺でね
何かしっかりしてる だから接点があるんですね
仏教を全くもうこう捨てる人とは大変難しいんで
接点見つかるのもね まあまあ別にどうってことないんですけど
とにかく開眼宗っていうのは
いろんな儀式 儀礼やってやった上で
それで何か意味があると思うバカバカらしいことを
何の意味もないんです
儀式儀礼やっても というのは悟らない人にしかわからないんですよ
ですから その三つ煩悩がなくなったらソーターパンダと言うんだよと
アヴィニパータダンマ
ソーターパになったらアヴィニパータダンマ
堕落不可能な人になる
この堕落不可能ということは
人間界より下はいけません
生まれ変わっても人間のレベルで止まる
人間でも堕落して生まれません
例えば身体障害とかね
知能障害とかね そういうふうには生まれません
しっかりして生まれる
アヴィニパータダンマ
ニヤタサンボディパラヤナ
必ずも必ずも解脱えられる
これは個人的な主観なんですけど
証拠はないし会ったことないんですけど
テスラーモルという人がいたんですね
あの人の哲学をずっと読んでみると
どこで勉強してたっていうこともないんです
一応イギリスで インド人ですけど
かなりインテリ教育させちゃったんだけど
させた教育は全部捨てちゃったんです
彼が神様として次の現代の世界の宗教家として育てられたんですよ
ある宗教グループから
宗教といっても別に特別な宗教を求めるってではなくて
世界的に統一してる真理求めようというなんとかの学派なんです
言葉忘れちゃったんだけどね
そこからその人を選んで
この子供の頃からこういう人だとね
選んでイギリスに連れて行って育てちゃったんです
だから宗教みたいな色々勉強してしっかりした知識得たんだけど
大人になった途端 独立できた途端
今まで教えたものは全部捨てたんです
自分を育てたあの組織も捨てたんです
捨てて語り始めたんです
弟子一人も使う 彼がいっぱい弟子を作ってシステムを作ってくれると思ってたんだけど
一人も弟子はいらんと
すっごい語っていた でも内容を見ると
この人 やっぱり生まれ時はもう預流果ぐらいには智慧が開いているということはものすごくそうではない
そうではないという そういう速度は自分の頭に出ている
出なきゃこれは言えないんだと
こういう風なポイント
こういう風に説明はできないんだと
だって西洋にはそういう師匠はないし
インドにもそういう師匠はないし
この人は実体論ばっかり教えてもらって叩き込まれて
全部捨てて不思議に覚るんですね
だから彼の欠点といえば方法論を持ってない
もう仏教も受け取ってないんだからね
仏教も組織化されている宗教だから
彼にとってはもう面白くない
だから彼にとって何かは知ってるんだけど
それはみんなにこの言葉で理解して欲しがっちゃうんですね
やっぱり預流果だけはこの言葉聞くだけでも心が変える可能性はあるんです
彼がそこを狙っていたんですね
分かってくるかもしれません
だから方法論を持っていなかったことで
ちょっとなんかみんな迷っちゃいますけど
でも直接彼の話を聞いた人々がそうなりでもなかったんですね
だからそういう 今私は知っている例で言えばね
それ一人の人物なんですけど
もしかするとね それは私のあくまでも主観であって
自分の勝手な判断ですけど
あそこまで喋れるんだったら
覚醒で預流果には悟ってないとダメじゃないかなと
2番目に私は好き勝手に思っているのは
自分生まれた田舎のお寺にいた住職さんのお坊さんなんです
子供頃から知っていたんだからどうも不思議なんですね
誰にも計算できない でも決して威張らない
まるっきり単なる田舎者で
いろいろ冗談言いながら
みんなとふざけながら
みんなと草を取ったり
掃除をしたり あとは子供たちと遊んだりとかね
だからもうみんなすごい
もう誰とも人気はあるんだけど
心は読めない 何があっても困ったっていうことを一度も見たことがない
人間だから世界だからね
毎日いろんなものを問題が起きるんですよ
ある時は本当にもう解決できないほどとんでもない問題が起きちゃったんです
これに困ったのは私だけなんですね
私が即った問題ではないんだけど
私はあっちこっち走って走って
いろいろ解決方法を見つかって
何とかしてね 結構時間もかかりましたけどね
解決しましたけど このお坊さんが
それだけ困って困って困って
私自分から悩んでるんだからね
言ったら まあいいんじゃないか
まあもう何ヶ月間くらいちょっと困ったっても
もう何ヶ月間か困ったらいいんじゃないですかね
私にとってはね これはね
あの人に今言えばね すぐもうやってくれると思いますけど
で 言わない 何々さんが頼めばまあ大丈夫と思いますけどね
でもでも 2  3ヶ月は来るのでいいんじゃないか
そういうこともこそこそそれ私にだけ言うんですね
他の人にそれも言わない
だからまあ心の中身はまあ私にはそういうことでも辞めちゃったんだけど
まあやっぱり役に立たんなっていう
自分でやらなくちゃいかんと
やってくれないと でも嫌っていう気持ちが出てこないんですね
無執着の状態だからね
何があっても そこでまあ学校で教えてたんだからね
もうお金を遣う道はなかったしね
まあみんなに配ったりとかね
それでお寺いろいろいっぱい
いろんなもう信者さんからお金もらわない
全部作ったりしましたけどね
で 何か法事なんかあろうと思って
まあお金一応集めてまとめておいたんですね
全部なくなったみたい
それはどうやって？みんなものすごく笑って
あのうちはお金がない
なくなったんです そういう風に
なくなったんだけど なんかすごい面白い話してるような感じ
誰が持ってる？なんで
それでみんなに言っちゃって
私はすぐ おそらくこれ大変な額ではないかと
自分だけ みんな ああそう
あんな風に気楽に言うんだから
先生どれぐらいですか？と
ちょっと調べましょう
これはね ちょっと額なんですけど
私だけにちょっと額なんです
だからまあいいよ 私はみんなこの大体私は結構いろんなランクの人々を知ってるし
私は聞いたら言ってくれるんです
取った人でも あんたでしょって言ったら
はいと言うんです 違うと言えないんです
だから じゃあまあ調べます
まあまあいいよ  まあまあいいよ
それはもう だから調べるために必要な一つも情報がなかったんです
全く だからすごいだなと思いますよ
もう微かに自分の部屋に入っても
もうすぐいっぱい人が出入りするんだからね
まあこういうこういう人が来たんだよとか何かでも言ってくれたら
私はそんな関係では調べますけど
でも一人も何一つも言わない
まあまあいいんじゃない
向かった人に悪いよ だからもうなんでそんな性格っていうのはね
やっぱり小さい時からもう私が知ったその人
それはそういう性格だからね
やっぱり過去から持ってこないと何にも取らわれないということはね
それで怒りと欲少ないということは
ものすごい桁外れたもんなんですね
だから預流果よりは上やと思いますけどね
それは直接知ってる方で
弟子においてなんか会ったこともないんですけどね
我々の時代ではなかったんだからね
もっと前の時代の人でしたし
ですから 預流果に悟っても一来果に悟っても人間の世界に生まれ変わる可能性はあるんです
生まれ変わっても その人々は小さかなちっぽけな人間というわけじゃないんです
人気者になるかならないか別なんですけど
ものすごい大胆な人格で生きてて
戻るということはないです
俗世間に堕落するなんてそれだけはありえないという
そこで最後のエワン・スワッカーテ・ビッカウィ
このようにぴったしと私は喋っているんだから
ダンマを説いているんだから
オープンにしているんだから
それを聞く比丘たちの中でイエーテ・ビク・ダンマーヌサーリの
ダンマーヌサーリっていうのは法に従って生きている
アヌサーリっていうのはこの思考のことですね
だから自分の人格 思考
全部法によってコンディションというかね
仏法そのものなんですね
何考えたって何か評価したっても
仏法の目でしか見ないような
この自分と一緒になっちゃう方が
悟っているとどころじゃないんです
ただ勉強して理解して
なんかもう一緒になっちゃって
もう離れなくなっちゃう
お釈迦様の教えがね それがダンマーヌサーリ
サッダーヌサーリ サッダーっていうのは信仰のことで
やっぱり仏説こそ正しいと
他のもの絶対正しくないと
ものすごく納得している
まだまだ悟っているというところじゃないんです
もう狂暴といえば狂暴な
他の人の話なんか聞けない
仏教だけですよという
もうすごい信頼 信仰があると
それは正直にね サッベーテ・サンボーディ・パラヤナ
それだけでも感得は与えられるんだと
悟りたい悟りたいと それはなくても
自分の人格 生き方そのものも仏教そのものになってしまえば
それでも必ず解脱を得られる
それぐらいすごい教えですよと
本気になって信じただけでも十分だよと
本気で信じなくちゃいけないんです
信仰は意味がないんですけどね
信じるということは確信ですからね
理解能力は必要なんです
それでまたもう一行付け加えるんですね
このように立派に喋っているこの教えに対してイエサン・マイ・サッダー・マッタン
マイ こんなすごい説法したブッダに対してサッダー・マッタン
ちょっとした こんなちっぽけなお釈迦様って偉いなとか
すごい方だなという信仰ぐらいあれならば
ペーメ・マッタン お釈迦様に対してほんのちょっとファンになったならば
ファンになったならば
ペーマっていうのはお釈迦様のことを愛するという意味なんですけど
それは現代語ではファンなんですよ
ブッダのファンになったならば
大したことはないんですけどね
仏教ってすごくいいことや
もうお釈迦様は私の気に入りだとかね
ブッダのことは というぐらいになったぐらいだけでも
サッガ・パラヤナ 天国には生まれ変わりますよと
地獄には行けないんだ
ということで 仏教のはっきりしたことと
シックス・ウェルというところで結論して終わっちゃうんです
この経典は だからこのヘビね
ヘビを間違って取ってはいけないんだと
とんでもないことになるんだよというところから
しっぽで捕まえるんじゃないんだよとね
頭で捕まえてくださいと
話でこのアリッタさんが性欲をそんなに邪魔にならないんだ
といういい加減なことを言った
俗世間の人から見れば
そんな別に大したことはないとね
と思う可能性はあるんですけど
お釈迦様の仏教ではそういうところではないんですよ
ものすごい巨大な尊い哲学を語っているんだから
そんな下らんことを言ってはいけません
で 性行為って何なのかとわかってないんだから
性行為っていうのは この遺伝子がとにかく自分で生き続けたいだけ
我々は騙されているだけ
とにかく遺伝のコピーを残したいだけ
別に自分の子孫でも何でもないんですけど
子孫作れませんから 生まれた子は全く別な遺伝子を持ってるんだから
それでいっぱい生命を作って何か得られるも何もないでしょうに
だからそこを正当化すること
性を正当化することをやって解脱とは全く反対なことなんですね
ですから そんないい加減なくだらないことをね
言うなよと あなたはもうダメだからあっち行けと言って
お釈迦様はそこからなぜ仏教って偉いかということを
そこからずっと話しかけたんですね
ですから この入り口のエピソードが
経典を拡げる時には使ってないんですね
そのエピソードは 一般人の考え方のレベルの低さと
仏教というのはどんな目で世の中を見ているかという
この共有した世界であるということを言うために使っただけ
お釈迦様が取ったポイントはヘビの例えです
蛇の例えから経典説法を始めたんですね
蛇使いがやっぱり蛇捕まって聖者になりたいと思うならば
ちゃんと頭を捕まえなくちゃいけないんですね
尻尾を捕まったらかえって逆に
だから仏教は歪曲しては絶対にダメだということなんです
歪曲できません 改良もできません
これ改良できるというのも冗談じゃないんで
できるはずがないんですよ
わかっている人にとっては
こんなに明確に語れないですね
無我論はこんなに徹底的に語れないですよ
これ厳密に論理だから
我っていうのは感情でしょ
我があるかもしれませんと
感情であって希望的観察なんですね
我があってほしいと なんで我があってほしいと希望が生まれるかと
ずっと死んじゃいますからなんですよ
そんなに我にしがみつく必要ないでしょ
人が死なないんだったら
毎日物事変化する 体が病気になる
うまくいかない 納得いかない
人生は不満だらけで苦しみだらけで
だから希望的観察で我に我という概念にしがみついているだけ
科学的な根拠はないんです
だから人間が我を語ること自体
ブッダにとっては人生はドゥッカであるということの証明なんです
ドゥッカだからこそ みんな何かにすがっているんですね
それもある妄想概念 すがっているものを実体として見つかるんだったら
私は何も言いませんよ
ただの妄想概念 その妄想がなければ生きていられないほど人生は苦しいんです
天国に永遠の命あるんだよということを消してもらえば
人々というのは本当にもう殺されるかもしれません
そんなこと私なんか言っちゃうと
極楽道なんか あんなインチキな話は世の中でありえないと言っちゃうと
もうどうなるかわからないぐらい怖いんですよ
だからそれぐらい人間というで生きることは苦しいんですよ
ですから 天国でも英団でも極楽道でも何でもいいんです
何か希望的妄想概念作ってもらえば
単なる希望的妄想概念ですね
そこからこの話を続けてきましたので
私の話はここで終了いたします
理解できたかどうかはわかりませんが
大体やっぱりサイキの身ではすごい理解難しいと思います
これはまあ出家道士において喋ると結構喋れます
[背景の雑音]